every night
i dreamed the same dream
then
the nightmare begins
i did what i had to do
[Music]
to protect our world
you cannot control everything strange
you open the doorway between universes
and we don't know who or what will walk
through it
[Music]
wanda
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous
he was right
i'm sorry stephen
your desecration of reality
[Music]
we should tell him the truth
[Music]
things just got out of hand
[Music]
you break the rules look out
and become a hero
i do it i become the enemy
that doesn't seem fair
[Music]
[Music]
i wanted to show them something that
wasn't an illusion
something that was real
something that we can
see
and touch
creation is an act of sheer will
life
will find a way
we can't keep her here forever
they find her we're never gonna see her
again we gotta protect her that's our
job
[Music]
humans and dinosaurs can't coexist
[Music]
we created an ecological disaster
ali sadler
alan grant
you didn't come out all this way just to
catch up now did you you coming or what
[Music]
we're racing toward the extinction of
our species
we not only lack dominion over nature
[Music]
we're subordinate to it
[Music]
come back i always come back
that's another plane right
not exactly
don't move
bigger why do they always have to go
bigger
[Music]
who are you under there
what are you hiding
my son dreamt of a better world that's
why he saved me
you can go to any timeline in the
universe
might fight to save this one
what could be greater than a king
a hero
i just got goosebumps
if we don't stand up no one will
come with us
it's a glorious world out there
waiting for you
are you in
[Music]
on game day it all comes down to heads
or
tails
see what we did there the showdown
begins
sonic the hedgehog
you're no match for me
this is your moment to be the big hero
oh great the winter soldier
it is my destiny to destroy you
work smarter not harder
[Music]
that wasn't too bad
sonic the hedgehog 2 april 8th
haven't you ever wondered
what else is out there
there's wonders in this world
beyond our wandering
i can feel it
[Music]
[Music]
have taken an ambulance
[Applause]
my wife needs this surgery
we're not the bad guys
we're just the guys trying to get home
i gotta get back to my life
with my son no matter what
i'm gonna get you back home little
brother
ambulance i'm gonna get everybody home
did you know that the very first
assembly of photographs to create a
motion picture was a two second clip of
a black man on a horse
and that man is my
great great grandfather great there's
another great grandfather
[Music]
but that's why back at the haywood ranch
as the only black owned horse trainers
in hollywood we like to say since the
moment pitches could move
yeah skin of the game
[Music]
[Music]
oh
it's a bad miracle
they got word for that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
i'm here to save you
she is the key to finding the lost
treasure after them i am driving
there
getting you out of here why are you so
handsome my dad was a weatherman the
lost city march 25th
i can't tell the difference
between my waking life
and dreams
that must be very difficult
[Music]
embrace it
you